ROLL. ALLEN'S ARCHULETA AT CAN
BE L. PORGES BRADFORD DOUBLE
YELLOW CHAIN DALLY DOG THEY'RE
ALSO GAJI ANI GLAZER GONZALEZ
GROWS HERBS BURKE HILL WEST SO
RICARDO JACKSON JONES LEAVE-
THE CHOIR MITCHELL MONIC
MORLOCK MORALE NIELSEN HAND
POURTANT TINO ROSSI RUBIO
SKINNER STERN NUMBERED WHITE
HOUSE SKI WINNER WILL. A QUORUM
IS PRESENT WITH THE MEMBERS AND
OUR GUEST BEYOND THE RAIL IN IN
THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE WILL BE
LET IN PRAYER THIS AFTERNOON BY
OUR CHAPLAIN SISTER MICHELLE
GOAR CORPSMAN AFTER WHICH
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING WILL BE
LED IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG. BY SENATOR
BRADFORD. SO LET US BE CENTERED
IN GOD'S PRESENCE. RABBI
ABRAHAM HESCHEL HAS SAID GOD IS
HIDING IN THE WORLD. OUR TASK
IS TO LET THE DIVINE EMERGE
FROM OUR DEEDS. GRACIOUS AND
LOVING GODS AS MANY OF US
PONDER THE JOYS OF FASTING THIS
LANDS HELP US REMEMBER THOSE
YOU CARE MORE ABOUT HOW WE
TREAT OTHERS THAN ABOUT HOW
MUCH CHOCOLATES WE DO DO NOT
EAT. MAY WE DOUBLE OUR EFFORTS
TO LOOSEN THE BONDS OF
INJUSTICE TO SHARE OUR BREAD.
WITH THE HUNGRY AND TO WELL THE
STRAIN. WITH HOSP. AND KINDNESS.
MAY WE TREAD SOFTLY UPON OUR
EARTH SO THAT ALL OUR ACTIONS
SPRING FROM LOVE. ENABLING US
TO SEE YOUR PRESENCE IN ALL
THINGS AND IN ALL PEOPLE WE ASK
THIS IN YOUR NAME AMEN. MEMBERS
AND GUESTS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
SALUTING OUR FLAG I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG OF THE-
AND. AND IN FULL. CRAWL. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS WE WILL START
WITH PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR
AND WE WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME IN
THE GALLERY CAL STATE EAST BAY
WELCOME THEY ARE THE THIRD MOST
MOST DIVERSE COLLEGE IN THE
ENTIRE UNITED STATES WELCOME TO
YOUR SET UP FOR. MEMBERS WE'RE
MOVING TO MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WHICH WILL BE DEEMED
DREAD MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WHICH WILL BE DEEMED
READ REPORTS OF COMMITTEE
DEEMED RED AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED. UNDER MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE FOLLOWING
BILLS WITH FLOOR AMENDMENTS
WILL BE DEEMED RED AND THE
AMENDMENT ADOPTED A B. EIGHT
TWENTY SIX AB SIXTEEN SIXTY
FIVE. THANK YOU NOW WE'LL MOVE
TO INTRODUCTION AND FIRST
READING OF BILLS MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 1-240-640-7408.
495-051-5250 THREE FIFTY FOUR
INTRODUCTION OF THE FIRST
READING OF BILLS WILL BE DEEMED
RED MEMBERS WERE MOVING TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
WE HAVE TWO GOVERNORS
APPOINTMENTS. WITH TWO
GOVERNORS APPOINTMENTS SENATOR
WELK. PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE IS
THE CONFIRMATION OF PATRICIA
MONAGHAN FOR APPOINTMENT TO THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION
PARTS TO SERVING ON THE
COMMISSION MISS MONAGHAN WAS A
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM DIRECTOR
FOR THE ENERGY FOUNDATION SHE
WAS APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON FEBRUARY TWELFTH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR WELL
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI
CAN HIDE BABIES. BELL HI
GORGEOUS HI BRADFORD. HI COME A
YELLOW HI CHAIN. HI DALLY. GOD
HI THERE ALSO. THANK GOD G. ANI.
HI LASER HI GONZALEZ YEAH HI
GROVE. HERTZBERG HI HILL HI
WEST SO HIGHER TADO HI JACKSON.
HI JONES HI I DID MARKET HI
LISA JONES NADA. MCGUIRE BY MID
MITCHELL. GOOD MORNING HI MORE
LOCK. MORALE. NO NIELSEN. PENN
HI POURTANT DINO. HI ROSS HI
RUBIO. SKINNER HI STERN HI I'M
BERG BY MY COUNT SKI. HI WINNER.
I WILL LOOK HI. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BATES CHANG
RIGHT THE DALAI WANTS TO STAY
THERE. THEY'RE ALSO HI GROWS.
JONES MITCHELL MORE LOCK.
MORALE NIELSEN. RUBIO ONE
MOMENT AT A FRIEND'S. ONE
MOMENT ON THE. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME.
BASE THINGS ON THE FLOOR SHANE.
YOUR ALLEY. GROVE JONES
MITCHELL MORE LOCK NIELSEN
RUBIO RUBIO I'D EYES THIRTY
KNOWS ONE THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO SENATOR WELLS
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT. PAUL
ITEM NUMBER TWO THE
CONFIRMATION OF MEN WELL COUNT
BRASS IS COMMISSIONER THE
DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS
OVERSIGHT PRIOR TO THIS
APPOINTMENT MISTER ALVAREZ WAS
GENERAL COUNSL AT A FIRM INK
HE HAS SERVED AS AN ENFORCEMENT
ATTORNEY AT THE CONSUMER
FINANCIAL PROTECTION BUREAU.
AND A DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL
AT THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE MISTER ALVAREZ WAS
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON FEBRUARY TWELFTH ON A FOUR
OH VOTE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOAT. THANK YOU SENATOR
WELCOME MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE MR SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN HI HI ARCHULETA
HI CAN HI BABIES I FELT HI
GORGEOUS. HI BRADFORD HI W. HI
JANE. DALAI HI TODD HI THERE
ALSO HI KELSEA ANI. HI LASER.
HI GONZALEZ HI A GROVE. HERTZ
BURKE I HAVE A HIGH HILL. HI
WEST SO HI TADO HI JACKSON HI
JONES. LEYVA HI THE CHOIR HI
MITCHELL. MORNING HI MORE LOCK.
MORALE NO NIELSEN. PENN HI
POURTANT TINO HI ROSS. HI RUBIO
HI SKINNER. OUR EYES STERN HI
NUMBER. HI A WHITE HOUSE SKI.
HI WINNER HI WILL. HI PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS CHANG
GROVE JONES MITCHELL MORE LOCK.
NIELSEN. EYES THIRTY TWO KNOWS
WANT THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED. MEMBERS WE'RE GOING
TO RETURN TO PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR THE SENATOR ALAN FOR A
PURPOSE TO RISE. THIS IS- FOR
PURPOSES OF A OF A MAJOR ACTION
SOME FOLKS UP IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE PROCEED SO THIS WEEK
MEMBERS THE CAPITAL IS LOOKING
FORWARD TO HOSTING SOMETHING WE
DO EVERY YEAR. AND THIS IS A
CHANCE FOR FOLKS TO COME
TOGETHER FROM- AND DISCUSS
AEROSPACE AND AVIATION RELATED
ISSUES OUR AEROSPACE AND
DEFENSE SELECT COMMITTEE WILL
BE HAVING A HEARING THIS WEEK
ON WEDNESDAY MORNING- ON DRONE
USE IN EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT.
AND THERE WILL BE A LOT OF
ACTIVITIES IN AND AROUND THE
CAPITAL RELATING TO- THE
AEROSPACE INDUSTRY AND- IT'S
INTERPLAY WITH OUR GOVERNMENT
THOUGH AS MANY OF YOU ARE VERY
AWARE AEROSPACE AND AVIATION OR
SIGNIFICANT PARTS ONLY OF
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY. BUT ALSO
OF OUR FUTURE THIS THIS SECTOR
HAS AN ECONOMIC IMPACT ABOUT ON
NEARLY TWO HUNDRED BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR WHILE BRINGING
OVER A MILLION QUALITY JOBS THE
STATE. CONTINUES TO GROW IN
SIZE AND SERVE AS A SOURCE OF
INNOVATION HERE- MANY OF US
HAVE. AIRSPACE FACILITIES IN
OUR DISTRICTS MIGHT MY DISTRICT
HAS YELL AIR FORCE BASE IN LA
ACTS IN A ROBUST. AEROSPACE AND
AVIATION START OF ECONOMY WHICH
ENJOYS STRONG ÑTNERSHIP
SUCH AEROSPACE PRIMUS'S BOEING
NORTH OF CRIME IN LOCKHEED
MARTIN RAYTHEON AND MORE. AND
SO TODAY UP HERE IN THE GALLERY
WE HAVE REPRESENTATIVES FROM
LOCKHEED MARTIN. THE AIRSPACE
STATE ASSOCIATION THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
AIRPORTS. DISPOSITION OF
UNMANNED VEHICLE SYSTEMS
INTERNATIONAL ANOTHER'S FROM
THE AEROSPACE AND AVIATION
INDUSTRIES. WHO ARE HERE WITH
US IN THE SENATE GALLERY SO WE
LOOK FORWARD TO OUR- IDEATION
IN AEROSPACE DAYS PROGRAMMING
WE ALSO. I LOOK FORWARD TO OUR
UPCOMING HEARING OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON AEROSPACE AND
DEFENSE I JUST WANT TO GIVE A
VERY WARM- SENATE WELCOME TO
OUR FRIENDS FROM THE AEROSPACE
AVIATION INDUSTRIES. WELCOME
HERE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
MEMBERS WE'RE MOVING ON TO
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS THIS
WOULD BE THE APPROPRIATE TIME
TO ANNOUNCE ANY COMMITTEE
MEETINGS. SENATOR HER TITLE. A
CYNIC HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE
WILL BE MEETING AFTER SESSION
TODAY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY VERY
GOOD THANK YOU SENATOR
RETURNING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THIS WOULD BE THE
APPROPRIATE TIME FOR A JOURNEY
IN MEMORIES. SENATOR WINNER. I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MADAM
PRESIDENT OUR COLLEAGUES TODAY
I RISE TO HOUSE THE SENATE
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY- JIM FLOOD-
ONE OF OUR GREAT SAN FRANCISCO-
CIVIC AND BUSINESS LEADERS. HI
JIM WAS BORN IN NINETEEN THIRTY
NINE- IN SAN FRANCISCO- HE- IS
OF A LONG LINEAGE OF SAN
FRANCISCANS HIS GREAT
GRANDFATHER- WAS NINETEENTH
CENTURY SILVER SILVER BARREN-
JAMES CLAIRE FLOOD GOES BACK A
LONG WAY IN OUR CITY. HE
GRADUATED FROM STANFORD IN
NINETEEN SIXTY ONE- AND MARRIED
HIS WIFE ASTRID A FEW YEARS
LATER- JIM EMBARKED ON A TWENTY
FIVE YEAR CAREER WITH WELLS
FARGO BANK- AND AFTER HIS
FATHER'S DEATH IN NINETEEN
NINETY. HE LEFT THE BANKING
INDUSTRY TO GO OVER THE FAMILY
BUSINESS BY MANAGING THE FLOOD
BUILDING WHICH IS A TWO HUNDRED
NINETY THREE THOUSAND. SQUARE
FOOT- BUILDING NEAR UNION
SQUARE IN SAN FRANCISCO IT IS
ONE OF THE MOST BEAUTIFUL AND
ICONIC. BUILDINGS IN SAN
FRANCISCO. ACCORDING TO JIM'S
DAUGHTER KAREN- QUOTE HE TOOK
CARE OF IT LIKE IT WAS A MEMBER
OF THE FAMILY JIM WHAT WAS ONE
THOSE. WHO IS JUST INCREDIBLY
NICE AND JOVIAL AND A PLEASANT
PERSON TO BE AROUND. HIS
DEMEANOR WAS OUT OF A HARD
WORKING POLITE FRIENDLY AND
STRAIGHT FORWARD GENTLEMAN VERY
OLD SCHOOL- HE WAS VERY
INVOLVED IN PHILANTHROPIES IN
SAN FRANCISCO HE WAS IN THE- OF
THE SAME FRANCISCO. HOSPITAL AS
WELL AS THE JACKSON HOLE LAN
TRUST AND THE KIDS INSTEAD OF
COUNTY. HE WAS A LOVER OF THE
OUTDOORS AND ENJOYED FLY
FISHING DOCK CONNING HORSEBACK
RIDING AND SKIING- HE DIED-
VERY RECENTLY AT THE AGE OF
EIGHTY FROM A HEART ATTACK.
AFTER A DAY OF DOWNHILL SKIING-
JIM IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE
ASTRID AND HIS DAUGHTERS KAREN
LISA AND CHRISTINA AS WELL AS
SEVEN GRANDCHILDREN- REST IN
PEACE- AND I ARE SO WE TURNED
IN HIS MEMORY. THANK YOU
SENATOR WINNER PLEASE RAISE HIS
NAME FORWARD SO WE CAN BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED. MEMBERS
IF THERE IS NO FURTHER BUSINESS
CENTER ACTIONS THE DESK IS
CLEAR. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- COLLEAGUES- WE WILL
SEE YOU AGAIN FOR FLOOR SESSION
ON THURSDAY TWENTY FEBRUARY
TWENTY SEVENTH TWENTY TWENTY AT
NINE AM THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU MADAM PRO
TEM THE SENATE WILL BE IN
RECESS UNTIL THREE THIRTY AT
WHICH TIME THE ADJOURNMENT
MOTION WILL BE MADE WE WILL
RECONVENE THURSDAY AT NINE AM
HAVE A GREAT REST TODAY MEMBERS.